like time wise when would when did you
go to africa
i want to say march
february of this year february of 2021
right yes so talk about that trip
because that's kind of a interesting
time we're kind of like
mentally feels like we're over the
pandemic even though shit's still hot
you know what i'm saying but like how
was that trip man
um
that trip was
by the way first time there no that was
my second time in nigeria i had been to
abuja okay which is the capital i hadn't
been to lagos which is like the old
capital where it's way more history and
stuff way more people in lagos
um
that trip was interesting man because
um one traveling during you know
pandemic time or whatever we want to
call this era
um
it's just it's a heavy lift you know um
that like literally the airport
experience is a whole different
experience when you enter in another
country during that time so
it's damn near traumatic because it's
like
you know uh you're getting stopped a
million times i got threatened like
within the first within the first uh
15 minutes i got threatened to get
arrested because my mask wasn't over my
nose you know what i'm saying oh my god
it was below my nose and she was like
lift your mask above your nose
i was like okay for sure haphazardly and
i'm talking though so i'm talking and my
mouth is opening up and down like yeah
shanks we got this and then the other
discussion where we going what the plan
is
they come back down i got two bags in my
hand so i'm not thinking about it she's
like if i have to tell you this again i
am going to have you arrested
and i was like
i was like down smokey down like that
because i wanted to be without you're
not
i wanted to be like man i don't want to
have to sock on those security guards if
you'll have me arrested make sure the
real police come yeah because it's too
early the plane ride was too long
like and we had already gotten stopped
so many times that i was
it had to be connecting flight right oh
absolutely
we might have flying flown through
london or something yeah
and so but of course
that was all going on in my head i
pulled up my mask and was all right
and it just what gets me is they always
got like they always got the black
people policing the black people you
know what i'm saying they got somebody
like my auntie telling me pull up your
mask you know what i'm saying and i know
she's just doing her job but
you know it just ends up in and me
feeling violated like leave me listen
the world has gone
[ __ ] crazy the world is [ __ ] crazy